As a young boy, Bruce witnessed his parents' murder...
...at the hands of an unidentified mugger.
Bruce's life was dramatically changed from then on...
...as he vowed to avenge his parents' death.
Longtime butler of the Wayne family Alfred Pennyworth...
...arranged so that Bruce would not be taken into social service care.
As a teenager, Bruce Wayne departs on a journey around the world...
...to learn all the skills needed to become the crusader he envisioned.
Bruce Wayne then returned to Gotham City, a city rampant with crime and corruption.
A bat flying through his window gave him the inspiration to transform himself into Batman.
Batman has no superpowers.
Instead, he uses his fighting skills, scientific knowledge...
...and exceptional detective abilities to fight crime.
Perhaps the most famous bat-inspired object used by Batman is his Batmobile.
During the day, Bruce Wayne plays up a lifestyle of a superficial wealthy playboy...
...in order to hide his crime-fighting alter ego.